singer-songwriter and record producer
Raphael Saadiq has been working in the
music industry for more than 30 years I
remember he started his career with the
R&B group Tony Tony Tony and later moved
on to solo work the Grammy Award winner
has collaborated with such stars as Mary
Jay fly
John Legend and Whitney Houston after
eight years Sadiq recently released his
latest album Jimmy Lee and says it's his
most honest work yet CBS this morning's
Anthony Mason sat down with him at a
penthouse recording studio here in New
York Raphael Saadiq says his new music
may be his most honest ever I went down
the rabbit hole and I said you know this
it's time for me to talk about it we
surprised it what came out I'm very
surprised at what came out yes as a solo
artist and before that as a member of
the R&B group Tony Tony Tony who scored
a string of hits in the late 80s and 90s
Siddiq became known as a musician who
could swing easily between styles but
there was one subject he stayed away
from in his music his family and a
series of tragedies he's indoors
the 53 year old singer has named his new
record Jimmy Lee after his older brother
who died of a heroin overdose
he was an addict you know people look
down on addicts he was sort of the black
sheep of the family he was looked at
like nothing to a lot of people so why
did you choose to name it after him
cuz he was everything to me Jimmy was
everything to me he was you know like I
always say on my shows I'll he would
drop off a puppy leave it in the
backyard for me are you know always want
something really nice Jimmy Lee was just
one of four siblings Sadiq has lost his
brother Desmond also an addict committed
suicide in 1987
mother brother Alvey was murdered by my
sister's boyfriend when I was seven and
my sister was in a car accident and I
just always kept progressing and moving
forward in you know but you carried it
with you so I carried it may I have them
tattoo tomorrow my four of them been
alone for over 20 plus years yeah it has
to have affected you in some way it made
me a little hard it made me not respond
to simple things that people respond to
them I'm like what's your deal yeah you
know I think whether you complaining
about that a Steinway piano is that
there is there before me a big huge
black Steinway piano was is I felt like
that's all the therapy I need yeah music
works wonders man it's amazing yeah it's
incredible
[Music]
the album he says is for anyone who's
had a Jimmy Lee in their life do you
feel like you read something in a way I
feel like I've freed the energy to
spirit a little bit also I guess that
one of the biggest things I'm watching
my mother through this process it's
pretty cool your mom gets here this
record yeah it's pretty sweet yeah this
is sweet she's 86
she's an artwork mm-hmm so she
definitely wants to see it she's like
where's my record I'm gonna see his late
brothers and sister are also in the
album artwork for Jimmy Lee
that's pretty trippy for me mm-hmm did
you need to put it all someplace do you
think I've always said somehow I need to
connect the dots and I feel like I'm
finally connecting the dots for myself
and also for people who's been you know
listening to me for all these years